A team of engineering students
at the University of California
San Diego have entered
themselves into the Google Lunar
X privately funded space program
with a proposal that's, uh,
considered unusual for science,
but typical for San Diego
college students.
Uh, they want to make beer in
space, and from a scientific--
(laughter)
I know.
From a scientific standpoint,
their goal is to study the
effects on the yeast, which
could lead to a better
understanding of how to make
other foods in space.
However, it's possible that this
plan to binge drink on the moon
could just be the latest attempt
by the Russians to undermine us
with a space contest they could
actually win for once.
Yeah, that's right!
Sweet burn, Russia!
That was for Laika the space
dog!
(laughter, cheering)
Uh, so...
Comedians...
if this idea becomes a reality,
what's a transmission NASA might
receive from a team of space
drunks?
Jeff Ross.
>> One small step for sobriety,
11 more steps to go.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Very good. Very, very good.
(laughter, applause & cheering)
Mike Lawrence.
>> This is ground control.
I'm major bombed.
>> HARDWICK: All right, points.
Very good.
(laughter, applause)
Jamar.
>> Houston, we have a drinking
problem.
>> HARDWICK: Yes. Points.
(laughter, applause & cheering)
>> That's good.